. All right, let's have some fun.
We are going to do a whirlwind tour through
the last 24 hours on Fox News as Joe Biden
officially won the Electoral College.
Donald Trump lost it.
We already talked about this officially yesterday,
December 14th, state electors voting and Joe
Biden got three hundred and six electoral
votes.
It is over.
It was over before.
It's extra over now.
So all sorts of people appeared on Fox News
and they were dealing with this loss in a
variety of different ways.
Joe Biden said during his speech last night
when he addressed the nation that Donald Trump
attempted an assault on democracy in trying
to steal the election.
And that's accurate.
And that leads to our first clip.
Here is Donald Trump's press secretary and
senior campaign adviser, which one she was
last night, I don't know, reacting to Joe
Biden's accurate claim about Donald Trump
trying to assault democracy.
And she's really upset, guys.
And this just before coming to air, we heard
Joe Biden say that there was an assault on
democracy by President Trump asking for a
free and fair election.
That's preposterous.
How fitting is your monologue tonight?
The assault on democracy.
Was the four year attack going after President
Trump the basis Mueller allegations the the
impeachment over a one whistleblower with
hearsay.
So she's very upset there are at least pretending
to be and this is just so simple, but they
want to make it more complex.
Joe Biden won this election because he won
enough states to get more than two hundred
and seventy electoral votes.
That's it.
And then Donald Trump, despite losing, tried
to remain in power.
So it is an assault on the Democratic will
of the people, period.
End of story, very simple.
They either don't get it or they pretend not
to get it.
Here's Laura Ingram in our next clip, sort
of begrudgingly conceding that it is President
elect Joe Biden, but she had to do it in a
sarcastic tone.
OK.
Take a look.
Following the Electoral College vote today,
President elect Joe Biden spoke to the nation
tonight.
Listen, as long as you acknowledge that he's
president elect, I don't care if you use a
Mickey Mouse voice.
I don't care if you say President elect Joe
Biden as Chewbacca.
I don't care as long as you're understanding
that Joe Biden is the president elect, this
next one is just delightful.
Even Trump supporter and friend of Trump,
Geraldo Rivera, has to admit it's over and
wild Trump sycophant Charlie Kirk just can't
take it and starts arguing with her.
Although live on air, let's first listen to
what Geraldo had to say.
The modern history of our country.
But to persist in insisting against the Supreme
Court, against the scores of lawsuits that
have gone against him, every single one of
them that he won, that's why these people,
they believe him.
They love him.
They are following his lead.
It is the president who is instilling in these
people the false sense that they have been
gypped.
Charlie makes a point that there are so many
affidavits here or there.
You litigate each one of them.
If someone's guilty of election fraud, you
put them in jail.
The attorney general of the United States,
William Barr, said that there is no fraud,
that he is seen of a scope large enough to
affect the outcome of this election.
That is going to come in here.
Charlie, go ahead.
So I'm not thrilled with her.
Aldo's use of the words gipped.
It's sort of like saying you've been Jewed.
I'm not canceling her, although it's not the
main point of the clip, but I've stopped using
that term.
But the sentiment here is correct.
And Charlie Kirk doesn't like it.
And if you try to say something sensible on
Fox News, you get attacked.
And that's what happened here.
And here's Charlie Kirk, very upset with Haraldur
elections were very much on the margins, especially
in Georgia and Arizona.
And you suppress that conversation, but it's
not healthy for our country here, although
that raises a question for six weeks, all
that we have litigated this for six weeks,
twice the Supreme Court of the United States
have rejected it nine to nothing, including
all three justices, but rather you have this.
So that's pretty funny.
They just can't take it.
And then as a sort of contrast, here's the
news side of Fox News, which is often not
very newsy, but even they did say yesterday,
Bret Baier saying Joe Biden has officially
won.
Well, what is normally a rubber stamp process
was anything but today.
And moments ago, the Electoral College voted.
For president and what may be its most watched
event in decades, making Joe Biden the forty
sixth president of the United States right
now President elect correspondent Brian.
Yet such an uncontroversial statement, that
one from Brett Bair, which got Magga Twitter
absolutely furious with Bret Bair.
And these are some wild times that we live
in.
And a little bit later, I'm actually going
to talk about a very interesting sort of milestone
for Fox News, a negative milestone regarding
ratings.
And the bigger picture is I am very curious
to see what Fox News will look like January
21st and beyond.
Not that much longer now.
We'll know very soon.